i hope you love this clip as much as i
love magic spoon makers of the most
delicious healthy cereal in the world i
love you magic spoon and thank you for
sponsoring this clip
i mean this is awkward but it's safe to
say that
that you didn't get paid a whole bunch
to be in the new jackass movie
yeah we can we can say that
i mean it kind of makes sense because
like yeah it's like it's like i would
[ __ ] if i'm investing in this huge movie
and i got these new guys i don't know
what they're about i'm not going to give
them [ __ ] a meal and be like oh yeah
well
[ __ ] well right i mean the idea is that
i didn't i didn't like perform what they
wanted you know and then it's like
pretty much a waste of their money so i
think it was kind of like let's see what
they got first and then maybe we'll
[ __ ] what it's like
dude you're like i don't know when we
paid marcus you're like all right dude
this guy's in for it let's double it you
know well right but that's me like like
i like uh the the the world doesn't
operate the way i do you know like the
mentality of yeah you're [ __ ] a
legend you're genius dude the the
mentality here is
did these kids get to be on jackass they
were like fans of jackass growing up and
now they get to be able to fight like we
don't have to pay themselves we'll do it
for free probably for free yes so you
know
um so yeah they got a little advantage
on their side you know
for sure i mean and then they're not
wrong i mean they're not wrong it's like
what are you gonna not be in a big room
oh sure you know like it's like oh if
you don't you won't do it for free then
then i guess you're not gonna be in the
movie of course you're gonna yeah [ __ ] i
would be like [ __ ] it i'd be like i'll
do it for free right dude like like our
buddy zeke who i introduce you to who's
just a [ __ ] badass surfer yeah he
kills it we've been hanging out a lot
yeah jacob zeke is achilles shout out to
him yeah shout out jay
he told me some crazy [ __ ] that you were
like telling him that you were like in
in
trouble with money
like
you know he was like yeah we're trying
to drive somewhere and then oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] dude this [ __ ] life's hard right
now man there's a struggle out here you
were telling me like i didn't have any
gas money like i'm broke
dude
like i'm right now if i show you my bank
account it's in the red so we got it is
that because you you're bad at spending
or just because you know you didn't have
a lot of money coming in
over two years of that jackass money
because covid kept hitting and hitting
you know and we had to get postponed and
everything so like through all those you
know
two years of living you got expenses you
got you know costs i mean i just
just living you know and all my all my
bills and [ __ ] just [ __ ] and you got
that new truck yeah i got my new truck i
needed my new truck though because i
didn't have a car
and i was like dude there's one thing
i'm getting and it's my dream truck and
you're taking chicks out on dates and
you're like [ __ ] it i'm spending money
um there was a point when i was eating
really good yeah but i'd always think
you know i shouldn't have thought that
though i was always thinking i'll be
fine you know i'll get another it'll
come back money come back you know right
but yeah [ __ ]
so dude let's the struggle's real dude
yeah let's uh let's figure out some
chunky are you on cameo i got cameo is
that uh that helps yeah
what are you charging for 100 bucks okay
and uh how often are you getting them i
get one like um once a week maybe
okay can we
love my cameos dude they're like [ __ ]
psyched i get like 10 stars can we
please and i mean this genuinely
everybody listening
to this podcast can we please
get
cameo orders coming in for poopies and
t-shirt sales and can we please oh dude
i got i'm sitting on merch dude i
haven't sold a t-shirt i don't think in
like a month oh dude bro yeah those
shirts rule we gotta sell those shirts
yep so that's two s's in a row poopies
yeah stores yeah there's two s's cool
okay and i got i got three shirts
designs presumably the store is linked
in your instagram bio yep so i got a
whole link tree of all my platforms okay
so if you click my link tree on my
instagram bio it'll take you to all of
my stuff you ever thought about doing
only fans
um i have but
i mean
i don't know how to do it
i don't like
only fans is like for chicks and like i
don't know dude i think
i think tiga tyga is like top three well
there's so many platforms like you could
how do you say
tiger tiger yeah you guys want to see
poopy dick click here no
missionary like focusing like yeah yeah
yeah they can watch your rehab you
should do your cameos while you're
missionary like
no
i got kids fans so like i don't i like
the i love the groms we call them groms
you go to magicspoon.com
stevo and that's gonna get you five
dollars off your order and you can get
this trial kit it comes with your fruity
your frosted
your cocoa
and your peanut butter i mean come on
you can't go wrong the stuff is
delicious and it's actually good for you
so go to magicspoon.com
and for good measure use the promo code
stevo when you're there to get five
dollars off your order and find out how
absolutely delicious this healthy cereal
truly is